foreign
Amanda joins us up first in Charlotte
North Carolina Amanda welcome to the
show
Dr Nan how's it going
pretty great pretty great
um yeah so I just have a question
um looking for like some reassurance or
maybe not so much of reassurance
regarding purchasing a home next month
um my husband is a regular listener of
you guys and he's recently pulled me in
and we've become like big fans together
and I'm like well maybe maybe we just
need to reach out and get their their
input they would pay
um if we're making the right decision on
that so do you feel like financially
this is unwise right now
so I think so I haven't had any doubts
or anything leading up to this until we
started listening to y'all's uh podcast
Our advice so now you're like oh no yeah
maybe maybe we can revisit this yeah
some numbers here
yeah so
um let me start by saying that this will
be our second home we sold our first
house it was three bags kebabs for a
good profit earlier this year in March
uh sorry around in April so we bought it
in March 2020. great interest rate for
305 and we sold it for 500 this past
April so that was a pretty good return
Yes
um the reason that we decided to sell is
because we need we don't have children
yet we're in our early 20s and we needed
more space to grow into
especially since those three bats and
from our initial Health uh really turns
one was taken away to become an office
because now we've both since covid work
remotely
um so we need office space
um and then also our family they all
live like out of town so whenever they
visit it's not going to be like hey I'm
here for a few hours to get by it's
going to be an overnight type of thing
you know so we wanted safe for lunchable
comfortable
um and yeah to just grow into so um you
guys have done that
no we don't no we don't we don't have
any debt and you're renting my student
loans all right yes so currently yeah so
we've been renting since we uh sold back
in April the house that we're building
should be
finished
um next month we have 225 000 in savings
um our take-home income after taxes is
about 89.30
um and we have good credit uh we also
invest
um
each week in stocks so I feel like we're
pretty like financially sound right now
but uh going into the house you know we
locked in our mortgage rate mortgage
rate right now rates right now are crazy
um we when we first bought in 2020 we
had like a three percent you know first
time home buyers yeah
uh now our mortgage rate is 5.125 I know
that we can refinance like next year you
know when the time comes but
um that rate is higher
um what's the house costs comparatively
the house cost is 615. okay and you're
gonna how much you're gonna put down of
the 225. yes well we've already put down
34 000 earlier this year and we're
planning to put down an additional 180
from savings in our monthly payment
would be total not just printable but
total would be 26.35
and that's on a 30-year or 15.
30. okay uh well I mean you're asking us
for advice it seems like this is uh this
train has left the station
has it I'm not sure I can't back out now
I want to make sure yeah well
contractually are you able to yes what's
stressing you out Amanda Amanda we're
okay
okay what what's making you question
everything
because this is such a like a large
amount of money that we currently have
in savings and like the world is just
crazy and I just want to make sure that
this is like a good
um investment to the homework we should
and they're like I know like the debt
um not the debt but isn't there like a
ratio you guys use for like here yes I
crunch the numbers for you it's about 30
of your take-home pay but that's on a 30
year if it was on a 15 year which is the
only mortgage we'd ever recommend it
would be much higher so it is a lot of
your take-home pay hopefully your
incomes go up you're also not on fire
this is not gonna like tank you guys
it's just gonna be hard to have margin
to do other things like invest 15 of
your income into retirement and say for
college and pay off the house early and
so so far a lot of your discussion has
been emotionally charged and there's not
enough room we don't have kids yet but
when we do and the parents are coming
they can't get a hotel we gotta it's
just been a lot of just emotional
instead of logical so that's my biggest
pushback is not you didn't need a house
it was just a reasons you've jumped into
this
sure yeah that's that's fair yeah yeah
so so I'm well and Amanda where you guys
are at we had a call yesterday that
um similar thing they were building
interest rate got too crazy now they
can't afford the how I mean it's like
this whole thing so
uh yeah the numbers are kind of tight I
mean for you guys for what we would
normally say yeah this is a smart move
you're a little bit above that I would
still keep three to I would put six
months in your emergency funds out of
that 225 keep six months uh aside just
to give you some more peace of mind
hopefully your incomes will come up to
meet this but but also Amanda like at
the end of the day yes your home is a
huge financial investment it's a huge
purchase uh but if you guys get a year
into this and you're like God we gotta
get out
you can always sell it I mean like it's
not ideal but you're not attached to
everything in life and so maybe it's
even got Equity since you guys have been
building uh but yeah your reasonings why
to do it but
hey you can enjoy it that's true well
you know it's not the house is not on
fire and it's not done being built yet
so keep saving and try to pay this long
thing off as quickly as possible this is
the Ramsay show